una escena de conmoción y tragedia en
este suburbio de la vida las calles
empedradas se tiñeron de rojo escenario
de los eventos que sucedieron más
temprano cuando un hombre armado abrió
fuego y mató a cinco personas
las explosiones sonaban me acerqué a la
ventana y vi al terrorista justo en
frente del edificio con un gran triple
m16 en ese segundo exacto saqué a mis
dos hijos el tiroteo no se detuvo la
casa simplemente estaba temblando se
podía oír desde todos lados la gente
gritaba ataque terroristas entré en la
habitación nos refugiamos en
informes de medios israelíes que citan a
funcionarios de seguridad no
identificados dijeron que el tirador era
un palestino de un pueblo cercano a la
ciudad de jenín en la cisjordania
ocupada después de asesinar a cuatro
civiles y un oficial el agresor recibió
un disparo mortal poniendo fin al tercer
ataque de este tipo en una semana 11
personas han perdido la vida en lo que
ha sido el pico más agudo de tiroteos en
años
y ahora estamos en el inicio de momento
desafiante hemos sido golpeados por el
terrorismo desde el comienzo del
sionismo no nos quebraron entonces si no
nos llorarán hoy el secreto de nuestra
existencia es la garantía mutua entre
nosotros nuestra determinación de
proteger el lugar que construimos a toda
costa ciudadanos de israel esta vez
también ganaremos ganvam a las condenan
cdad
si viene el presidente de la autoridad
nacional palestina mahmud abbas condenó
los tiroteos el estado de ánimo en las
calles de los territorios palestinos era
contradictorio pues los ciudadanos
corearon consignas y tocaron las bocinas
de sus vehículos para celebrar
[Música]